poursuivons notre série d'auditions dans
le cadre de la commission d'enquête Tik
Tok et nous avons donc le plaisir
d'auditionner Monsieur Alain bazo
président de l'UFC Que Choisir
accompagné de Monsieur Raphaël barthlom
responsable du service juridique
bienvenue à vous de Messieurs monsieur
monsieur Bazot vous êtes à la tête de
cette association depuis 2003 vous êtes
également membre de l'exécutif du Bureau
Européen des unions de consommateurs le
Buc en février 2021 l'UFC Que Choisir et
le BIC ont porté plainte contre Tik Tok
devant la Commission européenne et le
réseau des autorités de protection des
consommateurs
dénonçant des infractions au droit des
utilisateurs vous réclamiez une enquête
à l'échelle européenne et nationale sur
les pratiques de Tik Tok et demandiez
qu'une décision contraignante soit prise
par les autorités de protection des
consommateurs concernés pour mieux
informer les consommateurs sur sa
politique et son modèle économique
parmi vos principales critiques vous
insistiez notamment sur les techniques
publicitaires agressives ciblant les
mineurs et sur certaines clauses
contractuelles de TikTok pouvant être
considérés comme trompeuse pour les
consommateurs en juin 2022 TikTok s'est
engagé auprès de la Commission
européenne à mettre ses pratiques en
conformité avec les règles de l'Union
européenne en matière de publicité et de
protection des consommateurs les
autorités nationales de protection des
consommateurs sont chargés de suivre la
mise en oeuvre effective de ces
engagements des procédures sont en cours
dans plusieurs pays européens notamment
en Italie ou une enquête a été lancée en
mars 2023 vous pourrez sans doute nous
en dire un mot par ailleurs ayant
décortiqué le fonctionnement de Tik Tok
du point de vue de l'utilisateur vous
pourrez nous détailler les manquements
que vous avez observés en matière de
contrôle de l'âge deux politiques de
confidentialité deux publicités ciblées
ou encore de contenu dangereux et de
fraude
je me dois de vous rappeler que cette
audition est captée et retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et avant de
vous laisser la parole pour un exposé
linéaire d'une quinzaine de minutes je
vais procéder au formalités d'usage pour
les commissions d'enquête je dois aussi
vous rappeler qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquêter
passible de peine prévue aux articles
434 13 14 et 15 du code pénal et je vous
invite tous deux à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure
c'est bon il est allumé là
et bien je le jure
je le jure
ah pardon merci
et bien voilà vous avez la parole
messieurs pour une quinzaine de minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs mesdames
messieurs je voudrais déjà vous
remercier de d'auditionner mon
organisation du FC Que Choisir qui
effectivement
parmi ces nombreux sujets travail sur le
la problématique des réseaux sociaux et
spécifiquement sur Tik Tok qui a
des pratiques et un profil un peu
particulier
par rapport aux autres réseaux sociaux
donc vous vous l'avez dit alors c'est
une audition on nous a fait parvenir une
quinzaine de questions certaines sont
très techniques très juridiques c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai souhaité être
accompagné de Raphaël barthlomé que vous
avez présenté qui est notre responsable
juridique et qui suit ses affaires et
qui pourra en tant que besoin évidemment
répondre de façon plus précise technique
au sujet qui nous animent et puis je
vous avouerai qu'il y aura sans doute
certaines questions qui n'auront pas de
réponse la part de mon organisation
c'est que de choisir à pas
nécessairement réponse à tout et donc je
vous le dirai sans en bas je veux dire
qu'on n'a pas de réponse voilà alors
effectivement nous nous avons une
approche utilisateur association de
défense des consommateurs je ne vous
présente pas mon organisation
et son objet social et donc c'est vrai
qu'on observe TikTok comme comme
d'autres opérateurs sur la place dès le
départ en amont dès le téléchargement de
l'application tel qu'on la trouve dans
les magasins le Play Store le Google
Play l'Apple Store dès ce stade-là
d'ailleurs on peut déceler
des manquements par exemple et c'est
tout récent dans dans le c’était dans le
Google Play il était annoncé que cette
application
ne partagez pas ces données avec les
tiers
ce qu'il faut
donc on est intervenu ces services
juridique Raphaël carolienne lettres en
disant mais attendez alors c'est pas de
la responsabilité de Google c'est le
c'est l'annonceur qui qui décrit ce
qu'il est pour faire en sorte qu'on le
télécharge et donc un élément de
rassurance qui était complètement fou et
donc il a fallu une lettre quand même
c'est dire l'attention qu'on a porté une
lettre de dire attention vous n'êtes pas
dans les clous avec tous les menaces
qu'il peut y avoir derrière
les professionnels savent que l'UFC Que
Choisir mobilise toujours les outils du
droit les procédures etc en tant que de
besoin et on a obtenu grâce à cette
lettre déjà le fait de supprimer cette
mention qui était fausse dans à ce stade
vous voyez au tout début donc tout ça
pour vous dire que voilà on regarde dès
le départ jusqu'à évidemment le une fois
que c'était déchargé les différents
documents les conditions générales et
puis ensuite comment ça fonctionne on
fait des tests en se faisant passer pour
des usagers avec différents
âges et on voit en fonction de ce qu'on
regarde on regarde pas parce que c'est
une des particularités Tik Tok
la réaction après qu'est-ce qu'on va
vous servir comme comme contenu bref
voilà on se met dans la peau du
consommateur lambda en prenant plusieurs
profils voir comment ça fonctionne et
c'est là qu'on tire notre analyse et ça
on le fait depuis trois ans qu'on
regarde ce qui se passe et effectivement
on a décidé d'agir non pas
individuellement mais vu l'ampleur du
phénomène de travailler au sein avec le
Buck qui regroupe plus de 40
associations de consommateurs en Europe
et là on est parti avec je crois 18 au
total association qui avait envie de
s'investir sur ça
en introduction quand même signaler la
singularité de cette application de ce
réseau social Tik Tok alors c'est un peu
c'est pas dans le désordre ce que je
vais vous dire mais c'est vraiment les
faits marquants d'abord
le caractère extrêmement addictif on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont addictives le sucre il est addictif
etc mais là c'est particulièrement
prégnant
parce qu'il y a une hyper
personnalisation intraking très fin de
votre comportement et très rapidement
Tik Tok va savoir ce que vous aimez ce
que vous aimez pas ce que vous délaissez
etc et spontanément on va vous alimenter
en choses en événement en document dont
on a pressenti que c'était ça qui qui
vous intéressait avec des formats des
vidéos qui sont des formats courts ça
veut dire qu'on va pas se lasser parce
que ça va ça va c'est très rapide c'est
très rapide
autre élément c'est la facilité
c'est-à-dire que vous n'allez pas
chercher quelque chose
j'emplaris
la formule on vous donne la béquille
c'est à dire que vous dès que vous
ouvrez
l'application
immédiatement on va on va vous soumettre
tout un tas de documents de vidéo et
puis vous scrolez vous scrolez et puis
bon à un moment donné vous vous arrêtez
et vous restez combien à une seconde 10
secondes 20 secondes tout ça c'est
analysé pour comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure pour pour définir votre votre
profil de personnalité
et donc c'est alimenter automatiquement
donc il y a une passivité c'est pour ça
que je parle de un peu de gavage et on
sait excuser le parallèle mais quand on
gave des animaux des canards des oies on
sait qu'ils finissent par prendre
plaisir et que si on les gave plus ils
sont en manque là c'est exactement ça
c'est ça le caractère addictif lié à
cette facilité
cette enfermement finalement dans on
voudrait un portrait robot qui est
extrêmement fin
et puis la viralité c'est à dire la
viralité quand vous subissez enfin vous
subissez vous vous croyez que cetera
donc petit à petit on va vous proposer
les choses que vous aimez donc le but
c'est de rester sur Tik Tok évidemment
on est là en plein dans l'économie de
l'attention il faut capter l'attention
le plus longtemps possible
et donc on vous sert ce que vous êtes
censé aimer vouloir mais il empêche
qu'il y a la logique de viralité c'est à
dire que on va ici ou là
vous montrer à voir des vidéos qui
commencent à faire le buzz qui qui ont
un certain succès parce que ces vidéos
elles doivent étendre leur
audience et donc on va vous en amener
des nouvelles pour pour que vous veniez
alimenter la communauté et ça vient un
petit peu faire une distraction par
rapport parce qu'il arrive à un moment
donné si on se rend compte que vous vous
êtes en train de regarder comment on
fait de l'isolation de la toiture il y
arrive un moment vous allez en sortir
donc il faut aussi que petit à petit
ça ça reste distrayant
c'est une des forces de Tik Tok c'est
que c'est un du divertissement et ça ça
fait partie de
du succès qui se traduit par vous le
savez près de près de 15 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs par mois en France
sachant que le profil il doit être à 72%
de
d'utilisateurs qui ont moins de 24 ans
voilà on vous divertit on vous en
fermant
c'est extrêmement facile vous faites pas
d'effort
voilà
fondamentalement après il y a plein de
choses à dire les clés du succès
considérable de
de cette application
voilà un petit peu en
préliminaire
alors après du coup tout ça ne nous a
conduit à
vouloir dénoncer avec les collègues
européens les principaux manquants
et donc aller auprès de l'Autorité
Européenne qui est le regroupement
l'autorité c'est on leur pardon je
croyais avoir coupé mon téléphone et
c'était non ah non je suis pas
mais je suis pas
et puis en plus j'ai un blackberry je
crois que c'est des seuls sur la place
encore avoir un Blackberry enfin bref
oui donc le groupement des l'équivalent
des DGCCRF qui sont dans chaque pays et
donc il y a cette entité c'est une
procédure spéciale je peux le repère et
donc en gros on avait quatre motifs de
de tous ensemble de récrimination il y
avait l'aspect classique qu'on connaît
bien les clauses abusives je dis on
connaît bien parce qu'en plus c'est que
choisir fait partie de la commission des
Clos de la musique donc je vais pas vous
faire toute la liste mais c'était sur ce
sur ce fondement là des clauses qui
étaient floues
un droit à réutiliser les contenus alors
que ça c'est formellement interdit ça
doit être une clause noire je pense donc
automatiquement voilà donc déséquilibre
entre les droits obligations donc on
avait tout un paquet législation que les
abusives on avait tout un paquet sur
les PCT pratique commerciale trompeuses
et puis
les pratiques commerciales
PCD des loyal voilà
donc
par exemple sur tout ce qui est le
process d'achat d'article virtuel
ou après ça se transforme en argent dans
tout le process il y avait des
indications qui en réalité et été
trompeuses du marketing caché
effectivement de produits et qui est pas
de visibilité sur ça donc c'est une
pratique soit déloyale soit trompeuse
d'autant que l'enjeu c'était que les
destinataires ça pouvait être des
enfants donc j'allais dire presque
circonstances aggravantes peut-être que
juridiquement c'est pas le bon terme
mais en tout cas pour nous politiquement
le fait que ça touche des enfants c'est
c'est aggravant le troisième volet c'est
un autre globe de législation c'est le
rgpd tout ce qui est données
personnelles
avec des problèmes de visibilité sur
quel collectes
quel finalité quel but
et donc se trouvait posé la question de
la pertinence du consentement parce que
si on n'a pas une véritable visibilité
de qu'est-ce qui est capté aspiré pour
en faire quoi
comment est recueilli un consentement
dans ces conditions donc il y a le volet
de la du consentement et puis quatrième
axe ça concernait plus spécifiquement la
protection des enfants contre les les
vidéos suggestives un mot pour
ne pas dire que c'est essentiellement
des vidéos de nature érotiques
éventuellement pour ne pas dire plus
donc voilà ça c'était pour faire court
mais évidemment le dossier complet
pourrait vous être donné par notamment
le bug ou si vous voulez aller plus loin
dans dans les incriminations pas un
criminations mais sur les reproches et
les fondements juridiques
plus précis
alors vous vous demandiez mais je sais
pas si vous voulez proposer des
questions je peux dérouler si les
engagements puisque la procédure s'est
arrêtée
elle s'est arrêtée
et donc il y a des engagements qui ont
été pris par par Tik Tok est-ce qu'on
est satisfait des engagements est-ce
qu'ils sont respectés
alors par rapport aux droits de la
consommation stricteensus
on peut dire que que oui les Conditions
Générales d'Utilisation ont été
exurgés de ce qui était le plus
critiquable
et on a noté pour faire simple une
amélioration des pratiques considérées
comme trompeuse
mais en réalité le dossier pour nous est
loin d'être clos essentiellement sur le
terrain du rgpd
certes
ce que produit maintenant Tik Tok comme
document
c'est lisible
c'est bien écrit c'est fluide
mais en réalité ça n'est pas
compréhensible sur la réalité de ce
qu'ils font
sur l'ampleur de la collecte quand on le
lit on est on est bercé par une
une douce musique hawaïenne je dirais
mais on peut pas prendre conscience de
du fait que le principe de base du rgpd
qui est la minimisation
[Musique]
c'est à dire on ne prend que le minimum
des données
en réalité la vraie vie la vraie réalité
de Tik Tok c'est qu'ils prennent un
maximum de données
et donc par défaut ils prennent tout
alors que par défaut il devrait rien
prendre sauf à expliquer qu'ils prennent
ci qui prennent ça là quand on le lit on
ne se rend pas compte de la réalité de
ce qu'ils font
ensuite il y a la question du
signalement de contenu
du contenu
critiquable qui faudrait supprimer
une alerte d'un utilisateur
donc ça c'est c'est après coup c'est un
peu sérieux il s'est expost il y a
quelque chose qui est publié et comment
les utilisateurs peuvent réagir en
signalant on se rend compte que pour
l'utilisateur concrètement c'est assez
mal comme mode on peut pas dire que ce
soit mis en avant la avec une grande
facilité pour faire un signalement et
donc sauf à être un spécialiste un
redresseur de tort un procureur l'état
d'esprit de certains utilisateurs et
bien le la réalité fait que on va pas
forcément aller chercher tel endroit
Raphaël m'a montré lui-même qui est
assez féru de ça il m'a montré comment
c'était pas si évident par rapport au
code des indications qu'il y a sur les
applications c'était pas évident que
c'était à cet endroit là que on pouvait
manifester cette envie de faire un
signalement
et à cet égard d'ailleurs il y a
également vous avez dû le voir le
rapport de l'arcom sur le sur la sur le
la question du signalement qui est d'un
constat assez net sur le le manque de
déficience de
et c'est parce que ça ne fonctionne
toujours pas que l'autorité italienne a
réouvert une enquête
parce qu'il y a en réalité pas
d'application des mesures pour renforcer
la protection des mineurs donc c'est
reparti côté italien les Italiens sont
très dynamiques sur ce sujet ça fait
partie des états les les plus en pointe
pour déclencher des
procédures on espère par ailleurs que le
DSA
réglera
réglera ce sujet c'est en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on
c'est ce qu'on espère alors c'est vrai
cette procédure italienne a été ouverte
récemment ça date de mars et
on n'en sait pas plus nous c'est que
choisir
pas plus que ce qui est sur la place
publique et que tout à chacun peut voir
donc voilà j'ai pas d'informations plus
plus précise sur l'état d'avancement de
de cette action des Italiens pas même
nos collègues italiens je pense pas
qu'ils aient plus de
voilà
alors ensuite
il y avait la question finalement de
l'état du droit est-ce que le cadre
légal il est satisfaisant ou le corpus
de règles il est satisfaisant ou pas
satisfaisant
vous devez savoir que les règles sont
nombreuses
on peut pas dire qu'on manque de règles
mais là comme ailleurs c'est un constat
qu'on fait d'ailleurs globalement c'est
une parenthèse sur le droit de la
consommation en France je le dis souvent
dans dans des Colocs on a des plus beaux
droits de la consommation en France même
s'il est largement européen mais il y a
aussi les traductions en France
le code de la consommation il est devenu
il était comme ça un droit qui devrait
être un droit du quotidien maintenant
faut être un hyper spécialiste pour le
comprendre l'appliquer et le grand
problème du droit souvent c'est pas
qu'il existe pas c'est qu'il est pas
appliqué c'est prennent déficient
d'efficacité donc il y a de nombreux
textes évidemment ça reprend un peu les
différents chefs de plaintes que je vous
ai énoncé il y a tout le droit de la
conso pure il y a le DSA il y a le rgpd
mais cela génère une multitude
d'autorité qui sont chacune sur leur
spécialité
et donc des autorités qui sont
soit différentes avec des différences
spécialités aussi bien sur le plan
national
on retrouve ce phénomène de
cloisonnement de plusieurs autorités qui
peuvent potentiellement intervenir et
également le fait que l'intervention
puisse être supporté aussi il y a plein
européen il y a le plan national et puis
une multitude d'autorité avec
des temporalités différentes entre une
autorité qui va mettre six mois pour
pour régler un sujet qui pour lequel on
va le saisir et puis une autre si vous
prenez l'acné l'irlandaise qui est la
tête sous l'eau qui va mettre deux ans
pour sortir une décision alors que
l'acné le Français doit mettre six mois
bon donc voilà et donc tout ça génère de
un problème d'efficacité d'effectivité
l'efficacité elle est pure au
rendez-vous
les CPC c'est
les DG européenne
le DSA ça va être la commission
le rgpd c'est la tête de réseau c'est la
CNIL où se trouve les autorités les
entreprises qui ont leur siège on sait
que c'est
l'autorité irlandaise
il n'empêche que sur certains chefs de
compétences les cnils Nationales
essayent quand même d'exister et sur
certains angles quand c'est pas vraiment
dédié à l'acné le
en ce moment irlandaise va essayer de
récupérer c'est pour ça que la CNIL
italienne
joue sa partition même l'acné le
française qui par exemple sur les
cookies les cookies la CNIL a un champ
de champ de compétence
et puis vous avez aussi des autorités de
concurrence en Italie par exemple
l'Autorité de la concurrence c'est elle
qui est saisie concurrence et
consommation elle peut avoir cette cette
compétence et puis ne pas oublier
l'arcome l'arcome qui est elle aussi sur
certains aspects sur les contenus quand
on est sur les contenus par rapport au
mineur ça va être la recom et donc voilà
la législation elle est là
et elle va du coup permettre par cette
ce manque de
d'efficacité elle va permettre
évidemment que les les professionnels
les moins vertueux et bien arrivent à
prospérer trop longtemps dans des
pratiques qui sont qui sont pas
conformes aux règles applicables
alors les CNIL il y a aussi le
rôle de la CEPD la CNIL la réunion des
CNIL
bon c'est pas il y a pas de rôle on va
dire
opérationnel de cet instant c'est un
instant de de coordination technique sur
se mettre d'accord sur la les
terminologies sur une certaine doctrine
mais
ça n'est pas à proprement parler une
instance ni de régulation ni de contrôle
sur dénonce des problèmes des
dysfonctionnements ça n'est pas cet
instant ce qui va pouvoir venir au
secours
c'est pas une super technique
comme on pourrait peut-être l'appeler de
nos vœux d'ailleurs plutôt que d'avoir
une CNIL référente
avec la stratégie tout le monde connaît
la stratégie que les tous les réseaux
ont mis leur siège social en Irlande et
du coup la pauvre petite CNIL
petite en moyen parce que j'imagine
qu'elle est elle est grande
partiellement dans sa compétence
donc voilà voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur ça sur cette première partie je
sais pas si vous avez des questions
complémentaires avant de passer l'aspect
du contrôle de l'âge ou des temps
nous enchaînerons par les questions
réponses on donnera la parole d'abord à
monsieur le rapporteur et puis au
collège qui voudront s'exprimer d'accord
très bien alors je déroule
alors il y avait une question sur le
contrôle de l'âge et le temps
il est temps d'écran
alors quand on ouvre l'application Tik
Tok
on la télécharge et on l'ouvre il y a
quelques renseignements de départ qui
vous sont demandés il y a votre nom
prénom je pense je pense qu'on peut
mettre un pseudo mais ils vont pas les
contrôler
une adresse mail
et puis on met l'âge
et en fait tout ce qui va découler après
sur le contrôle des contenus en fonction
des âges
tout découle de ça qui est le maillon
faible
vous pouvez mettre la date que vous
voulez donc c'est tout simple donc soit
vous vous êtes frangeux vous êtes un
adulte donc du coup vous allez bon s'il
y a une coquetterie par rapport à l'âge
où on se dit je veux pas voir que je
suis vieux on va se rajeunir moi des
choses comme ça mais
l'enjeu c'est est-ce que je suis mineur
ou majeur et là et pire est-ce que J'ai
moins de 13 ans plus de 13 ans parce que
Tik Tok dit qu'il est pas fait pour les
moins de 13 ans
mais il suffit que je dise que j'ai 14
ans pour qu'on voit pas que j'ai 13 ans
etc donc tout le reste est inopérant
quand Tik Tok nous dit
les live ne sont possibles que si vous
avez 18 ans si le premier renseignement
est faux évidemment que ça tombe même
chose les plus de 16 ans il faut avoir
16 ans pour certaines fonctionnalités
les messages directs la monnaie
virtuelle ils disent même attendez à
partir de 16 ans avant non
donc tout ça ça tombe ça tombe et alors
il y a quelque chose qui est très
étonnant
c'est que donc ça repose sur la
responsabilité de celui qui s'inscrit de
donner le bon âge une responsabilité
d'ailleurs qui peut pas être engagée
parce qu'il faisait si vous êtes mineur
la fortune encore moins de 13 ans la
capacité juridique je vais pas faire du
droit des mineurs mais la capacité il y
a pas de responsabilité avant la moins
de 13 ans ce plan civil ça je ne suis
pas engagé en réalité
et donc à la fois il dit ça et puis d'un
autre côté dans ces conditions dans ces
textes
il dit que son système est capable de
détecter l'âge
donc si Tik Tok est capable de détecter
l'âge il le dit lui-même
il me semble qu'on devrait poser un
principe de responsabilité de la part de
Tik Tok puisqu'il dit lui-même qui peut
contrôler c'est que si on le prend le
doigt dans le pot de confiture
c'est-à-dire qu'il a accepté des
personnes qui ont moins de 13 ans ou
d'autres qui ont moins de 18 ans
nonobstant leur déclaration ils
devraient être considérés comme
responsables d'avoir continué à
alimenter cet usagée cette utilisateur
alors qu'il s'est pertinemment une nous
dit-il l'âge qu'il a
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
l'Italie a ouvert une enquête on se rend
compte que les filtres etc mis en avant
par TikTok ne fonctionne pas et a
demandé à ce que on réouvre une enquête
par rapport au temps au temps des grands
alors là on se moque un petit peu du
monde par rapport à ce que a mis en
place Tik Tok
Tik Tok
quand on est mineur
au bout d'une heure
il y a une alerte
attention ça fait une heure que tu es là
tu es sûr que tu veux continuer
si tu veux continuer tu fais 1 2 3
continue de tout ce que j'ai dit avant
l'addiction c'est comme si vous disiez à
quelqu'un qui addict de la boisson
attention de vert est-ce que tu veux
vraiment boire le troisième
enfin c'est complètement surréaliste
donc en fait
ce système
ne fonctionne que pour les gens très
raisonnables qui sont paradicts
autrement dit c'est pas le public visé
ou bien discipliné des enfants qui sont
très respectueux qui sont pas dans la
contestation de la norme etc ce qui est
propre des enfants quand même
de privilégier des interdits
donc on voit bien que c'est une
protection qui est de façade qui est
complètement illusoire
en plus
cette protection a supposer qu'elle est
quelques vertus
dès le départ tout à ça l'illusoir parce
que si je suis mineure et je l'ai pas
dit je vais pas être repéré par
l'application puisque j'ai dit que
j'étais majeur donc je vais pas avoir
l'alerte
sauf à prendre encore une fois Tik Tok à
son propre jeu je t'ai dit que j'étais
majeur je ne le suis pas tu sais que je
le suis pas tu m'as pas fait l'alerte
donc du coup tu es en faute et voilà
mécanisme de responsabilité et de
sanction parce que souvent il y a un
problème de l'effectivité du droit
souvent elle vient dans la sanction est
trop peu probable ou quand elle est
probable elle est très peu dissuasive
enfin bon ça c'est toutes les techniques
des sanctions que globalement on connaît
bien en droit de la consommation c'est
c'est un des maillons faibles de du
droit de la consommation
voilà donc nous on se dit vous savez on
n'a pas de solution toute faite mais on
se dit à l'IFC Que Choisir que la
solution elle est peut-être très en
amont dans la régulation du temps
d'accès à Internet pour les parents
plutôt que de se dire on va réguler le
temps sur Tik Tok parce que après il y a
des contournements si c'est pratique toc
je vais aller sur un autre qui sera un
peu pareil donc etc et est-ce que la
solution c'est pas de donner la main
aux parents
qui ont qui exerce l'autorité parentale
ça s'est contesté par personne et qui
aurait avec les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet etc des possibilités faciles de
dire mais voilà tu as un abonnement
voilà sur ton smartphone ou même sur une
tablette ou un ordi et moi je considère
que tu peux y aller que de moi je sais
pas de 9 heures du matin à 21h et au
total une heure ou deux heures ou en
fonction de mes parents font ce qu'ils
veulent et du coup voilà ce serait une
régulation beaucoup plus
en amont c'est quelque chose qu'on
sur lequel on réfléchir on a pas
d'expertisé analysé toutes les
solutions possibles et voilà
alors instaurer il y avait la question à
se minorité est-ce que c'est 13 ans 14
ans 15 ans
pardon oui majorité oui une majorité
Internet une majorité d'accès qui serait
pas les fameux 18 ans mais bon
très honnêtement
c'est que choisir n'a pas de
n'a pas d'analyse sur ça on n'a pas
l'expertise on n'a pas l'expertise on va
pas s'improviser expert sur les facultés
cognitives des enfants à quel âge je
pense qu'il y a suffisamment de gens
très averti là-dessus nous on suivra des
recommandations mais c'est pas de notre
champ de compétence et d'investigation
donc on n'a pas
expertisé le sujet c'est pas notre
vocation et donc par votre conséquence
on n'a pas de positionnement
sur la politique de confidentialité
comme je vous le disais là je vais un
peu me répéter c'est que
c'est devenu lisible
ça politique de confidentialité mais il
n'est pas mais pas compréhensible sur
l'ampleur de la collecte
et donc là encore principe de
minimisation n'est pas respecté et le
consentement
n'est pas éclairé pour pour dire les
choses clairement par rapport à la
collecte de données
le LGBT vous connaissez bien
soit c'est une obligation légale donc là
une consentement soit si c'est dans la
nature du service si je demande à être
livré d'un bien évidemment que
j'ai donné mon livraison mon adresse
et puis il y a la fameuse catégorie de
l'intérêt légitime
et là
pour TikTok tout est d'intérêt légitime
pour eux
c'est assez simple alors il y a
y a
un aspect
pour lequel il faut le consentement
exprès
c'est pour la publicité ciblée
mais c'est parce que
c'est parce que
l'acné l'italienne
a obligé Tik Tok à le faire
et donc mon Tik Tok c'est pas contenté
de le faire en Italie ils sont bien
rendus compte que s'il le faisait qu'en
Italie de toute façon ils auraient sur
le dos l'UFC Que Choisir et puis les
Allemands etc tous les collègues donc
tout est légitime y compris d'ailleurs
le partage de données avec des tiers
pour eux tout ça c'est légitime pas
besoin de consentement express
et
publicité ciblé aussi il faut qu'on soit
encore Express mais parce que ça a été
ça a été quand même une obligation de
contrainte
le temps tourne voilà c'est passionnant
non non je vous remercie nous vous
remercions pour cette exposition très
complet mais si vous permettez je vous
propose de continuer par une séquence de
questions-réponses
et je vais je vais donner la parole
d'abord à monsieur le rapporteur afin
que les collègues qui ont des qui sont
posés puissent s'exprimer
merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président de cette
exposé préliminaire qui était
extrêmement intéressant
et que vous aviez
pratiquement terminé au moment où la
Présidente nous interrompu puisqu'il ne
reste plus que le quatrième partie en
définitive sur lequel peut-être je vais
m'efforcer de poser une ou deux
questions comme ça ça vous permettra
d'avoir l'ensemble de ce que vous aviez
de nous dire l'ensemble de ce que vous
n'aviez préparé mais d'ores et déjà sur
ce que vous nous avez dit
je voudrais
évoquer le premier point qui sont ce qui
est celui de la plainte de l'ensemble
des associations de consommation de
consommateurs et du Bureau Européen
vous nous avez dit que c'est plaintes
étaient actuellement suspendus si j'ai
bien compris ou l'examen de ces plantes
est suspendus en raison de l'engagement
de TikTok en juin 2022 de la prise d'un
certain nombre d'engagements
particuliers qu'en juin 2022
ma question c'est la suivante quel
crédit accordez-vous à ces engagements
vous avez commencé les overly quels sont
ceux qui à votre avis sont aujourd'hui
réalisés
quelle lesquelles ne sont pas réalisées
et
il y a-t-il un délai
pour lequel il doit être réalisé est-ce
que ce et s'il y a un délai est-ce que
ce délai est le même que celui de la
mise en place du DSA pour l'ensemble des
plateformes qui est fixée dans les mois
qui viennent je n'ai plus la date exacte
en tête donc c'est
la première question que je voudrais
vous poser
oui si vous le permettez comment on est
sur les les aspects très précis de la
procédure les délais etc avec votre
autorisation Raphaël pour vous donner
des précisions ce qui se
techniquement et juridiquement le
dossier
pour répondre sur la portée à votre à
votre interrogation
sur ces engagements quel est le crédit
le crédit potentiel a donné à des
engagements de modification d'une
politique de confidentialité ou de
conditions générales ça se modifie
extrêmement fréquemment et facilement
forcez le constater que s'il y a eu une
modification c'est le texte même des
conditions générales elles sont elles
sont même
extrêmement bien écrites c'est
il y a plus rien d'abusif c'est même que
comme l'évoquait à l'Amazon oui c'est
une petite musique c'est une petite
musique et sans les mêmes pour un
juriste un peu un peu gênant parce que
parce que des conditions générales se
sont des droits des obligations
respectives pour autant elles ont été il
y a une nouvelle mouture par rapport à
la politique du confidentialité il y en
a une applicable aujourd'hui une
nouvelle version applicable aujourd'hui
ce matin 7000 mots 7000 mots encore une
fois toujours cette même musique dans
dans la lecture
notamment la monnaie virtuelle cette
monnaie virtuelle les objets virtuels et
tous les abus que que que l'on peut
constater alors il y a eu la seule chose
c'est de dire ok à partir de 16 on va
différencier 16 ans 18 ans et en dessous
ce qu'il est possible de faire d'acheter
et d'utiliser pour autant comme ça a été
évoqué il suffit qu'à la première phase
je donne une fausse une
fausse date de naissance pour que c'est
un paravent en quelque sorte le
sentiment c'est beaucoup de paravent
l'impression que avant le sipissime et
l'intervention des autorités
il y avait une granularité il y avait
des aspérités dans les pratiques dans
les conditions générales dans les
politiques confidentialité et que depuis
que les autorités l'autorités sipissées
notamment est intervenu c'est devenu
lisse lisse de façades c'est vraiment
cette ce sentiment quel crédit
je donne un exemple sur le crédit
notamment le rapport de l'arcome de
décembre 2022 sur la lutte et la
suppression des contenus illicites
Tik Tok a dit qu'il allait le faire plus
attention notamment sur les contenus
et l'intervention en amont sur les
contenus oui c'est très lisse c'est
c'est propre en quelque sorte
juridiquement l'arcom nous dit on a
aucune donnée on a aucune efficacité on
a aucun dialogue on ne sait pas si c'est
efficace et comment comment c'est
comment c'est réalisé l'autorité
italienne 21 mars relance son enquête
alors sur ces éléments là sur vraiment
cette surveillance proactivité
un petit peu plus proactif de de la part
de Tik Tok donc quel crédit
ce sont des documents que l'on peut lire
et qu'on peut le télécharger sur le site
de Tik Tok ce sont des documents qui ont
changé oui c'est factuellement
maintenant est-ce que les pratiques non
les questions sont toujours là sont
toujours là nos interrogations en tant
que choisir et notre regard par rapport
au parcours utilisateurs mais aussi les
autorités italiennes et
françaises est-ce que le DSA doit
changer les choses
et dans la temporalité dans les délais
on l'espère clairement que au bout d'un
moment le dessin est notamment dans
cette surveillance
excentée enfin cette surveillance
proactive
oui on espère que le DSA et le fait
qu'il y ait une autorité une entité la
Commission européenne oui qui va qui va
être proche de Tik Tok oui qui va la
surveiller lui mettre plus de pression
parce que le dessin est attendu comme
étant comme étant le point de départ
d'un
c'est pas nouveau en plus ces
obligations c'est pas c'est des
obligations issues du DSN sont pas
nouvelles elles existent des déjà elles
sont un peu plus précises mais que ça va
être un nouveau temps pour un nouveau
temps de régulation au-delà de
l'affichage pardon si j'étais un peu
long
je poursuis ma question ce que vous avez
remarqué que vous nous dites c'est très
clairement pour synthétiser un respect
formel des obligations et dans la
pratique rien n'a changé ce que vous
avez constaté je suppose que la
Commission européenne saisie par
l'ensemble des des organisations le
constate aussi
est-ce qu'elle a réagi déjà
quelles sont ses moyens de réagir
quelles sont ces possibilités à ce que
constatons que rien n'a changé elle peut
dire nous interdisons l'application ou
est-ce qu'elle peut quelles sont ses
moyens d'agir dans la mesure où je pense
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord sur le
fait qu'elle est sans doute remarqué la
même chose que vous
le
l'action du Bloc a débuté en 2021 nous
avons fait un rapport en février de
vigne 23 sur on a sur TiK ToK on a revu
tous les éléments pour voir si ça avait
changé ou pas nous avons alerté la
Commission européenne on a voulu la
transmis les travaux complémentaires les
analyses complémentaires
alors la réaction sinon un accueil de
d'un nouveau rapport de de leur part
l'autorité avec une logique il faut
savoir que le règlement 6 ici est en
cours de remise à plat c'est à dire pour
optimiser améliorer et le cette réunion
des autorités de la DGCCRF
schématiquement et notamment sur le
volet sanction capacité parce que
potentiellement qu'est-ce qu'elle peut
faire
elle peut menacer elle peut déjà déjà
menacée et on sait que le dessin va lui
donner de vrai pouvoir opérationnels au
pot de un poids de sanction très fort et
à l'image du rgpd pourquoi le rgpd est
craint potentiellement c'est le montant
la sanction c'est le montant exponentiel
de de la sanction son existence la
taille du marteau en quelque sorte et
pour l'instant potentiellement la
Commission européenne aura un marteau
comparable toutes choses égales à partir
de notre intermédiaire pleine et entière
du dessin
mais aujourd'hui elle est au courant il
n'y a pas eu des réactions dans tous les
cas formel
sur du DSA
est-ce qu'il y a une date précise
parce que suivant certaines disposition
schématiquement
mis 2023 parce qu'il y avait une entrée
en vigueur
au fur et à mesure et là on veut la
Commission européenne vient de désigner
les
structures qu'elle va contrôler en
direct c'était la semaine dernière donc
Tik Tok et après ils vont avoir un la
date certaine j'ai un trou de mémoire le
ils vont voir un délai pour mettre en
place les différents schémas de dialogue
notamment dans le cadre de la
surveillance des contenus la
surveillance et la suppression des
contenus et ce contrôle se contrôle
direct de la commission je pourrais on
vous a pas envoyé le formulaire dans le
formulaire vous mettre ces éléments
complémentaires
je voulais vous demander si les
l'ensemble des plaintes que vous avez
déposées à l'époque et l'évolution du
dossier et public ou en tout cas s'il
n'est pas confidentiel si vous pouvez
nous le communiquer parce que ça nous
aiderait beaucoup dans la dans l'étude
du dossier
je voulais vous demander à quelle
société vous avez à faire lorsque vous
parlez de Tik Tok et lorsque vous
déposez une place est-ce que c'est la
l'entreprise britannique Tic-Toc limite
Duke qui est sans avoir une sorte de
chaise une sorte de chapeau de de
l'ensemble de d'un certain nombre de
pays européens ou est-ce que c'est
l'association la société française Tik
Tok SAS ou une autre
pour le Buck dans le cadre de notre
réunion c'est c'est la structure
TikTok limited cette structures là qui a
été qui a été
désigné mise en cause mise en cause pour
ce que ce qui évoquait à la base au ce
qu'on a fait il y a 15 jours lorsqu'on a
vu que sur le Google Play c'est une
information totalement fausse sur les
données là on a sollicité Tik Tok France
avec une réactivité marque pour Tik Tok
France la réactivité pour Tik Tok
limited était moindre c'est pour ça
qu'on est allé devant la Commission
européenne
quels sont les personnes physiques de
Tik Tok que vous avez rencontré
aucune
ça se fait par par échange de courrier
de mise en demeure ou de uniquement ce
type d'échange pas de pas eu de ni de
vous d'augmenter leur part ou de
propositions de leur part
l'ensemble des membres du bug et
nous-mêmes on est fréquentable et nous
sommes notre portée ouverte pour
dialoguer mais en l'occurrence les
Tic-Toc personne et vous avez dans les
mails des mails qui sont signés de
certains de personnes est-ce que vous
pourrez nous communiquer la liste des
gens avec qui vous avez été en contact
pour nous orienter dans la lorsqu'on
envisagera de dialoguer avec Tik Tok
merci beaucoup
la deuxième partie de ce que vous avez
monsieur le Président c'est sur le
contrôle de l'âge et du temps d'écran
là encore de le DSA va
mettre un
calendrier pour et donc une un certain
nombre d'obligations le problème
que soulève les plateformes c'est qu'il
n'y a aujourd'hui pas de compte de
mécanisme de contrôle d'âge qui soit
validé par les autorités alors est-ce
que cela veut dire que
la Commission
la mise en place du DSA ou les pays
européens de façon indépendante vont
laisser aux plateformes
le fait de mettre en place un système de
contrôle d'âge
et il y en a d'efficaces qui sont
aujourd'hui développés par des startups
avec une double anonymisation qui permet
sa conscience surtout la pornographie et
ce genre de choses mais évidemment les
mineurs sont particulièrement concernés
est-ce que
on va dire vous nous vous nous proposer
des contrôlages et en regard de si c'est
si ça marche ou est-ce que il est prévu
que les autorités européennes ou de en
France
mettent en place des ou des exigences
juridiquement validées sur sur ces
contrôles là je sais pas si je m’exprime
bien mais les plateformes disent on a du
mal on a du mal il faudrait on pourrait
difficilement le faire nous-même il
faudrait il y a des startups qui s'en
occupent est-ce que vous avez une idée
de de développement de ça je sais qu'il
y a plusieurs startups françaises qui
proposent des solutions et qui sont des
solutions tout à fait tout à fait
possible à partir de la double
anonymisation mais ce que vous savez
déjà comment ça peut se régler ce sujet
parce que le sujet il va venir tout de
suite dès la nuit 2023 avec
l'application du DS
vous avez peut-être plus de d'éléments
que moi
à mon échange à dire de réflexion de
responsabilité d'une association
en schéma global nous on est plutôt
partant
que ce soit pas des mécanismes laissés à
l'appréciation de chacune des
entreprises parce qu'après il va falloir
porter un jugement sur la pertinence les
risques effectivement
nous on espère qu'il y ait un
process harmonisé commun qui
techniquement soit
mis en place et imposée généralisée
comme l'idée d'avoir une identification
numérique parce que évidemment on sait
que c'est le problème des données
personnelles qui est derrière donc
comment fabriquer un clone de
identifie l'âge sans identifier la
personne si techniquement ce genre de
choses est possible moi j'appellerai
enfin mon organisation même si on n'a
pas pris de pollution formelle chez nous
c'est quelque chose c'est pour le moment
mais je sais pour présider comme vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure depuis si
longtemps le FC Que Choisir je sais que
dans dans notre positionnement on va
plutôt nous on soutiendra plutôt ce
genre de
d'initiative et d'encadrement
par les pouvoirs publics après là où
sont nés les différentes recherches je
sais pas si vous avez des précisions
vous nous avez
alors ça concerne à la fois ce que vous
nous avez dit sur les conditions
d'utilisation des fusions en
compréhensibles y compris par un adulte
qui n'a pas d'agrégation en droit
c'est un petit peu la même chose sur sur
les
le problème de des données
est-ce que l'opacité sur les
l'utilisation des données des
l'opacité ou plutôt la difficulté de
compréhension à partir du site pour
l'utilisateur et le même en matière de
de l'utilisation des données
c'est-à-dire que c'est on sait pas trop
ce qui ce qui se passe et on est obligé
de que de cocher la croix parce que de
toute façon on va aller plus loin et
surtout est-ce que cette opacité ou
cette difficulté de compréhension que
vous avez
à laquelle vous avez fait allusion tout
à l'heure distinctes des autres
plateformes est-ce que c'est beaucoup
plus
difficilement compréhensible beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus en décalage entre le
formel du texte et les pratiques que les
autres plateformes
moi je peux dire globalement que oui
TikTok ce singularise par une opacité
plus grande maintenant plus précisément
en quoi cette opacité est plus forte
Raphaël a peut-être des éléments
d'exemple plus précis de sa singularité
sur cet angle là
pour être concret Tik Tok c'est son
algorithme de
proposition individus enfin son
algorithme ce qui va vous proposer une
une
vidéo l'autre la prochaine vidéo la
singularité la particularité cette sur
opacité quand vous avez réussi à
déchiffrer d'abord ce qu'ils prennent
les informations effectivement
collectées c'est se demander la
singularité c'est qu'est-ce qu'ils en
font c'est vraiment ça c'est le point
d'orgue c'est on ignore comment ces
données sont utilisées pour
personnaliser les contenus il est une
chose de cibler les publicités de
d'influencer les comportements et ça
c'est une vraie différence
l'autre différence c'est la masse il y a
une masse par défaut de données qui est
mais toute chose égale les autres les
autres réseaux ou des applications
prennent aussi beaucoup de données mais
c'est vraiment on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
en font on je ne sais pas ce qu'ils en
font les termes se sont toujours les
formules habituelles pour améliorer
c'est pour l'utilisateur que l'on prend
tout ça et on va les utiliser pour
l'utilisateur il y a toujours cette
expression de améliorer l'expérience
utilisateur c'est qui qui est une phrase
superbe parce que ça ne veut rien dire
et pour Tik Tok oui le
suropacité
sur la façon dont vont être combiné les
données qu'il collecte les données qu'il
obtient d'autre part les données qu'il
infèrent c'est-à-dire qu'il déduit de ce
qu'il prend et comment est-ce que ça va
influencer cet algorithme cette boîte
noire en quelque sorte ça c'est
spécificatif
merci beaucoup en ce qui concerne les
l'utilise le recueil des données et le
recueil des fonctions des fonctions des
smartphones
est-ce que
Tik Tok
collecte beaucoup demandent l'accès à
beaucoup par défaut d'une part à
beaucoup plus de fonctions que les
autres plateformes par exemple est-ce
qu'ils demandent l'accès à l'agenda
est-ce qu'il demande accès à la
géolocalisation un certain nombre
d'autres choses qui vous paraissent pas
où exactement nécessaires et est-ce
qu'il est possible facilement ou est-ce
que c'est là aussi opaque de décocher
les
fonctions à laquelle on demande
d'accéder et si on les décoche est-ce
que ça fait
est-ce que ça dégrade l'application et
que ça l'empêche de fonctionner
correctement et que donc dans les dans
les faits ça oblige à garder parce que
vous voulez pas dégrader l'utilisation
[Musique]
donc
par défaut Tik Tok prend beaucoup
beaucoup de et recoupe beaucoup
d'informations
géolocalisation mais
les carnets d'adresses il va même
recouper votre cannelle adresse avec les
utilisateurs de TikTok il prend il
agrège et il fait votre portrait-robot
juste sur le volet cocher des cochez
c'est de l'intérêt légitime pour Tik Tok
c'est à dire que l'une des
particularités quand vous téléchargez
l'application Tik Tok sur un téléphone
sur votre smartphone c'est que vous êtes
surpris qu'on ne vous demande pas votre
accord
on ne par défaut c'est très surprenant
parce que d'habitude dans le processus
on doit est-ce que vous acceptez qu'il
aille dans le carnet d'adresses et ce
qui vous acceptez qui la géolocalisation
et là je parle pour ceux qui n'ont pas
Apple d'accord parce que dans les
iPhones c'est un peu plus protégé par
défaut par l'environnement Apple avec
Tik Tok vous n'acceptez c'est surprenant
on vous demande de rien on vous demande
pas d'accepter quoi que ce soit sauf la
publicité ciblée mais ça ça apparaît au
bout de quelques heures d'utilisation
c'est pas à bénitier c'est au bout de
quelques heures au fait ce que vous
voulez la publicité là vous pouvez dire
non c'est à dire que pour répondre en
venir votre interrogation est-ce que je
peux décrocher non c'est de l'intérêt
légitime c'est et c'est de l'intérêt
légitime et c'est là où il y a un
problème
un problème de compatibilité avec le
rgpd c'est à dire que alors que en
principe c'est la on dit previcy by
design
c'est par défaut
sauf si j'accepte d'eux au fur et à
mesure avec une granularité le fait que
ce soit de l'intérêt légitime
tout est noyé est-ce qu'il est possible
ensuite nous avons développé l'UFC
choisir un outil qui permet de voir ce
que ce que c'est de vous TikTok on prend
les données et on a on a développé un
outil qui permet de devoir vous n'avez
pas de la possibilité de désactiver
enfin
dans l'interface vous n'avez pas cette
possibilité là par rapport au site
internet alors
très très bref le site internet
habituellement les conditions générales
sont tout le temps en bas d'un site dans
le footer du site et bien celui qui a
réussi à atteindre le footer dans Tik
Tok excusez
le site de Tik Tok bien il est tenace
enfin il a du courage tout simplement
parce que quand vous scrolez
vous avez des vidéos qui qui arrivent
encore
dans tous les cas c'est la même
politique de confidentialité ce sont les
mêmes conditions générales qui qui
s'appliquent c'est exactement le même
texte
agréable
le même texte qui est qui est esthétique
qui est esthétique mais esthétique parce
que ensuite totalement incompréhensible
j'espère avoir
répondu aux différents éléments
oui
mais si monsieur le rapporteur a posé
toutes ces questions je vais donner la
parole à notre collègue Annick billon
merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur pour les
différentes réponses que vous avez pu
d'ores et déjà apporté à monsieur le
rapporteur je reviendrai juste très
rapidement sur le contrôle parental
puisque ayant fait un certain nombre de
travaux pendant six mois sur l'industrie
de la pornographie on a effectivement vu
que le non accès des mineurs est dans la
loi l'effectivité ne l'est pas nous
avions été proposés aux différents
ministères concernés par ce texte ses
travaux pardon
nos propositions avec notamment le
dispositif de la CNIL et de la pérenne
est-ce que vous avez un regard
particulier sur ce sujet puisque j'ai
même cet après-midi même un rendez-vous
avec Jean-Noël Barrault sur son
ministère sur sur le projet de loi qui
qui devrait arriver rapidement sur le
numérique notamment donc c'était ma
première question j'avais deux autres
questions rapides si vous le permettez
donc vous avez mis en place un outil
gratuit qui permet aux internautes de
découvrir quels sont les données
personnelles qui sont collectées je
voudrais savoir un est-ce que cet outil
est utilisé par quels utilisateurs et
quel est son son efficacité en termes de
finalement de réaction par rapport à ces
données collectées est-ce qu'il y a des
changements de comportement suite suite
à cette utilisation ensuite vous avez
lancé également une campagne qui je
hashtag je ne suis pas une data avant de
faire des recherches sur le sujet je
n'avais pas eu connaissance de cette
campagne donc comment vous la quelle
visibilité est là est-ce qu'il y a un
éco particulier puisque c'est quelque
chose d'assez récent je pense que vous
n'avez peut-être pas forcément de retour
là dessus
mais s'il y en a merci de nous en faire
part et j'ai également pu constater que
avec la plateforme du SC Que Choisir
était possible de demander une copie des
données qui sont collectées
et l'article que j'avais pu lire à ce
sujet disait globalement que
Tik Tok Instagram finalement même chose
les données collectées sont très
nombreuses puisque même Instagram vous
aviez des messages privés et reçus et
envoyés qui étaient collectés donc
comment situez-vous sur une échelle de
dangerosité les principaux réseaux
sociaux et donc ils tentent je vous
remercie
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui de pouvoir
vous donner les informations peut-être
qu'encore une fois Raphaël qui suit ça
au quotidien en art mais
avant de venir je pensais pas avoir des
questions sur notre opération je ne suis
pas une data on n'a pas encore fait un
point au côté d'administration sur les
ça veut pas dire qu'on en a pas en
interne dans les services mais
donc voilà moi j'ai pas d'éléments sur
sur le
quand on en aura un bilan ça on peut on
peut vous le communiquer mais là comme
ça j'ai pas été voir dans dans les
services
c'est un service de l'engagement parce
que c'est une campagne qu'on a menée
supplément national mais également avec
notre réseau d'associations locales vous
pourrez monsieur bazo nous envoyer les
réponses par écrit il y a pas de souci
plus tard
sur le terrain parce que c'est un
travail de proximité avec nos
associations locales donc là sans
qu'elle le fasse sur le terrain et
qu'elle nous remontre quand vous serez
prêt voilà je sais pas quel est votre
calendrier pour le rendu de votre avis
mais
voilà et sur notre outil pareil même si
vous avez des précisions par rapport à
la question sur l'utilisation de l'outil
contrôle parental c'est pas un sujet sur
lequel nous avons travaillé donc on a
pas suivi et on
n'a pas demandé à être auditionné ou
quand on fait classiquement qui est un
sujet consumériste on regarde les textes
si on veut se faire entendre on demande
à être auditionné on envoie des des
amendements etc on se positionne quoi
mais sur le contrôle parental c'est vrai
que c'est c'est une problématique je dis
pas que ça nous intéresse pas mais
choisir c'est renoncer on est déjà sur
tous les sujets de conservation dès
qu'il y a une dimension qui est plus
d'ordre familial je veux dire souvent le
Luna fait les associations familiales
sont très sur ce sujet là elles ont la
compétence expertise donc on les laisse
on n'est pas sur ce sujet sur ce sujet
là
vous aviez un complément sur les
questions sur l'outil sur
oui oui oui
[Musique]
majorité un peu
paradoxal pour très paradoxal de prendre
beaucoup de choses alors que on
refuse
nous avons développé deux outils un
outil pour montrer l'invisible parce que
quand vous demandez une copie des
données et je n'arriverai à votre avenir
interrogation c'est un fichier
totalement illisible incompréhensible
c'est un fichier technique c'est pas
intéressant et en gros c'est un
traducteur et de l'autre côté en effet
un générateur de faciliter l'exercice
des droits rgpd le rgpd c'est
intéressant au moins ou pas intéressant
mais c'est de dire aussi aux
consommateurs aux utilisateurs à tous
que il y a des petits trucs dans les
rgpd qui sont faciles mens mobilisables
sans avoir à le lire et en trois clics
on peut générer une une demande
et on propose même de suivre
le bon traitement de la demande par le
professionnel pour avoir aussi cette
visibilité là parce que il est bien de
faire la demande il est mieux qu'on vous
y répondre enfin et on veut donc ce sera
dans la note ce que l'on vous
que l'on vous établira dernier
interrogation était relative à une
échelle c'est c'est ça une échelle
ça peut être complexe
pour ne pas faire
on pourrait vous dire que connaissant
360 fois par jour votre position est
plus si vous bougez connaissant votre
vitesse
on sait votre altitude à quelle vous
êtes ce que vous faites ce que vous avez
vu que la fréquence de chez le médecin
je suis dans un restaurant
est-ce que c'est dangereux
pour celui qui a accès aux données
on peut savoir où vous travaillez où
vous habitez pourquoi parce que c'est là
où tout simplement votre votre téléphone
va le plus
flugué on peut on connaît toutes vos
habitudes enfin on pardon les grands
acteurs
connaissent toutes toutes les habitudes
est-ce que c'est dangereux on évoque les
réseaux sociaux on pourrait parler de
tous les applications
et pas simplement les réseaux sociaux
une étude d'Oxford nous dit que sur un
million qui ont ils ont décortiqué un
million d'applications on demande le
consentement que dans 3% des cas à la
collecte des données personnelles et il
y a plus de tracker dans les
applications dédiées aux enfants que
dans les applications dédiées aux
adultes et quand vous fermez une
application elle continue à vous traquer
c'est à dire que le tracking c'est
interap aussi donc est-ce qu'il s'agit
de dire que c'est danger ou pas
l'objectif c'est de faire comprendre à
notre sens à l'utilisateur que c'est pas
une fatalité ce n'est pas une fatalité
et qu'il a la possibilité de se faire
oublier
c'est plutôt que d'aller
paramétrer toutes les applications tout
sont téléphone donc c'est compliqué de
dire que c'est dangereux
et d'être anxiogène potentiellement et
de se dire bon je l'utilise quand même
le téléphone ici c'est de dire vous êtes
un acteur chacun d'entre nous on peut
être un acteur sans perdre d'expérience
utilisateur sans dégrader l'usage qui
peut être fait de ces applications de
des sites internet mais on vous adresse
une note plus complète je voulais quand
même
répondre à la question enfin répondre
sans répondre
à l'échelle finalement noter là la
dangerosité des différents noms
vous savez mettre une note c'est une
lourde responsabilité
vous avez posé la question sans doute
parce que vous savez qu'on a l'habitude
de le faire à Que Choisir on met des
notes on fait des tests et puis on met
14 sur 20 à tel smartphone ou a-t-elle
produit donc c'est vrai que c'est dans
notre cœur de métier de noter pour
donner une information conservateur des
fois c'est des étoiles une de trois
étoiles
mais c'est une grande responsabilité
parce que il est un fait que quand on
met des notes du FC Que Choisir on a
quand même une certaine notoriété
et quand on met une mauvaise note elle
produit ce produit
il a tendance à être quand même plutôt
délaissé par le marché et à l'inverse
quand on a bien un produit
il y a un engouement et on nous reproche
qu'on nous retrouverons pas parce que
les gens se précipitent il achètent et
donc
j'ai pas nous faire plus important qu'on
est parce que on n'a pas forcément cette
même audience et cette même capacité
d'influence sur sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que on est une association qui
avons encore à faire notre place de
visibilité dans l'univers numérique
d'ailleurs on s'en rend compte avec
notre opération je ne suis pas une data
le bilan sera sans doute pas j'ai pas
pris jouer les
oiseaux de mauvaise augure mais ça sera
sans doute pas à la hauteur de nos
ambitions parce que être visible dans
l'univers numérique autant
historiquement l'UFC Que Choisir a fait
sa place dans l'univers physique comme
étant un peu lafp de la consommation
dans l'univers numérique qui est
multiplié par 100 000 etc et être
identifié comme étant la Vigile là
l'autorité de référence pour un certain
nombre de choses on a encore des marges
de progression
mais malgré ça là aujourd'hui vous voyez
ce serait pas responsable de ma part
d'improviser un classement et de mettre
des notes chaque fois qu'on le fait on
le fait sur une base faut qu'on
définisse un protocole savoir sur la
base de quoi on met la note comment on
paramètre les différents critères pour
arriver à une certaine note vous voyez
donc voilà c'est peut-être décevant que
je vous dise je vais pas voilà le pire
du pire c'est TikTok même si on l'a dit
dans l'audition c'est quand même
assez gratiné globalement les reproches
Tik Tok mais de là à dire que lui il a 2
sur 20 et puis que Instagram lui a 6 ou
7 vous voyez bon c'est c'est une
difficulté pour nous pour être tout à
fait franc et
c'est la base de notre crédibilité c'est
l'expertise avant de donner une note
pour conclure peut-être je vais donner
la parole au rapporteur pour une
dernière question avant de conclure
d'aborder le quatrième volet que vous
n'avait pas pu aborder tout à l'heure
la première c'est le problème de vous
avez fait allusion à la problème de la
monnaie virtuelle sur TikTok et
notamment de la mode de la monétisation
des lives
est-ce que cela conduit à des arnaques
et est-ce que Tik Tok quels moyens se
donne Tik Tok pour les Parets pour y
faire pour y faire face
est-ce que ce est-ce que c'est moyen
sont sont suivis de succès
et deuxièmement deuxième problème de
contenu dangereux la multiplication des
challenges qui ont défrayé un peu la
chronique ces derniers temps notamment
sur les pincements faciaux etc et
d'autres est-ce qu'il y a une
multiplication de ces contenus dangereux
et est-ce qu'il y a plus de ces contenus
dangereux de ces défis etc sur Tik Tok
sur les autres
applications que sur les autres
plateformes
bon évidemment Raphaël pourra compléter
mais sur l'explosion des challenges je
vous avouerai qu'on n'a pas mis en place
un dispositif de surveillance pour voir
quelle est la tendance bon
encore une fois faut pas oublier que
l'UFC Que Choisir et la première
organisation de consommateur de France
mais on reste une petite organisation
vous savez le service juridique de l'UFC
Que Choisir souvent de l'extérieur on a
l'impression qu'il y a une armada de
juriste combien vous êtes dans votre
service
pour couvrir ce champ là mais vous
imaginez il n'y a pas que celui-là
du logement du transport de
l'alimentation de la banque FAI enfin
bon c'est rien qui est énorme bon donc
tout ça pour vous dire que voilà on n'a
pas mis en place des fois on le fait
ponctuellement
on le fait ponctuellement un
observatoire des des arnaques des
fraudes sur un secteur parce qu'on sent
qu'il y a quelque chose et avant de
débouler si je puis dire soit en termes
d'alerte d'opinion publique soit dans la
revue soit devant les tribunaux on
constitue le dossier donc là je parle
toujours le contrôle de Raphaël mais on
n'a pas d'indicateur même si on que
c'est amplifié chez Tik Tok pour pour
des raisons qu'on reconnaît la logique
de de viralité les les
vues qui sont les les plus vues elles
sont promues donc il y a un effet un
effet boule de neige d'accélération
d'amplification de la diffusion de ces
fameux challenge
mais ça parce que c'est structurel au
modèle Tik Tok des enfants se mettent à
des enfants oui
et oui et donc comme ça commence à faire
le buzz par par ce système que on va
vous le mettre d'office pour vous
distraire voilà il y a un effet
amplificateur mais on l'a pas on l'a pas
chiffré voilà
et la tendance de du coup de Tik Tok
c'est de renvoyer à la responsabilité
des parents et de se défautier de sa
responsabilité
il y avait l'autre question qui était
sur la monnaie virtuelle c'est ça vous
avez des éléments sur la monnaie
virtuelle sur les arnaques la nature des
arnaques
par rapport à cette monnaie virtuelle
et notamment les lives les lives qui
spécificité aussi ça existe sur les
autres mais c'est une belle spécificité
aussi singularité de Tik Tok alors des
arnaques
oui oui
malheureusement
pas de la monnaie mais c'est cadeau
virtuel enfin en gros les emojis avant
leur transformation en diamant pour
ensuite être transformé en argent pour
être très schématique dans dans la
chaîne
alors des arnaques parce que
notamment certains vont abuser leur
notoriété leur influence enfin abuser
vont utiliser leur influence pour
promettre par exemple une vidéo où je
vais promouvoir le compte de si jamais à
celui qui me donne le plus des emoji à
celui qui qui va va le
c'est la rémunération enfin qui va me
donner de l'argent ce qui me finisse
c'est ça reste ça reste de l'argent
l'arnaque la plus répandue en ce moment
c'est l'échange de pièces gratuites il y
a plein de
années ça et ça disparaît rapidement les
arnaques tant que c'est pas très
schématiquement en tant que c'est
rentable et pas trop visible
c'est en cours et puis ensuite ça
disparaît pour renaître quelques temps
quelques temps après bon les l'arnaque
des pièces gratuites je démarre un live
je promets d'envoyer des pièces
gratuitement sur le compte du donateur
en échange d'un cadeau et en gros c'est
je si à l'amazone me donne une pièce
pendant mon live ou des cadeaux je vais
lui je vais lui en donner également
échange de de échange de cadeau bien
entendu j'ai une influence et une
communauté plus importante
plus importante et les utilisateurs
notamment du fait de leur jeunesse n'ont
pas n'ont pas les filtres n'ont pas les
filtres alcognitifs
n'ont pas la distance par rapport à la
fausse promesse et peut-être le
caractère grossier de l'arnaque oui
parce que tout est fait pour ne pas pour
ne pas de s'en rendre compte donc oui
des arnaques l'arnaque des pièces
gratuites ça surtout sur les lives sur
tout ce live sur comment est-ce qu'un
influenceur au sens premier c'est un
influenceur ou il y a une telle adhésion
à des ions de la communauté à une
personne à une personne qui fait des
vidéos mais une adhésion très très forte
très forte ou
je promets beaucoup de choses
qu'on rencontre partie de pièces on peut
faire des des
lives astroces d'astrologie à celui qui
me donne le plus de pièces donc donner
donner celui qui qui arrive donc oui
c'est devenu une gangrène c'est devenu
des pratiques des pratiques qui sont qui
sont identifiées et qui s'éteignent qui
s'éteignent mais qui Renesse un peu un
peu différemment café Tik Tok alors Tik
Tok
il y a plusieurs mesures qui existent
dans l'un des documents de contractuel
va limiter le nombre de cadeaux virtuels
qu'un utilisateur peut acheter ou
recevoir en gros pas plus 2 va interdire
la revente en dehors de l'application
ça c'est pas des les règles de la
communauté ont il y a un petit peu plus
de textes un peu plus de pages dans les
règles de la communauté par rapport par
rapport à ce à ce point là et Tik Tok
dit sensibiliser les utilisateurs au
risque liés à ces pratiques
ça c'est encore une fois de ce qu'on
peut lire dans les règles dans les
règles la question centrale qui se pose
c'est
à notre sens tant que
les cas de virtuels peuvent être
transformés en diamant qui peuvent être
transformés en euros tant que à la fin
l'argent qui est
dépensé par le primo enfin le un
utilisateur peut être transformé à la
fin de la chaîne en argent
ce type de pratiqueront toujours c'est
même si on va limiter éventuellement en
nombre ou en volume ce type de cadeau la
question est l'une des pistes qui
pourrait être envisagées c'est
simplement vous avez une collection de
diamants point virtuel et non pas la
possibilité de pouvoir le retransformer
en dollars avec en dollars ou en euros
pardon il y a les deux dans dans les
règles de la communauté
un cadeau vaut 100 puis au moment de
traduire économiquement il faut plus que
là il y a l'arnaque parce qu'il y a une
promesse qui n'est pas au rendez-vous
bien bien nous arrivons au terme de
cette audition c'est audition très dense
monsieur basot et Monsieur barthlomé
Nous vous remercions pour le temps que
vous nous avez consacré nous souhaitons
une bonne après-midi merci à vous